what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another episode of our
beyond omega level series where we talk
about the most powerful characters in
comics and the inspiration for today's
video comes from a viewer with the
username laffy waffy who commented that
they're still waiting for a beyond omega
level video on impossible man so today
we're gonna bring that waiting to an end
i do love that name i do love the name
laffy waffy so here's what you're gonna
do you're gonna send me a dm on twitter
and i'm gonna send you a rob core ring
so impossible man was created by stan
lee and jack kirby and first appeared in
fantastic four number 11 in 1963 which
stan lee claimed was the worst selling
issue of the fantastic four of all time
i don't know if that's true but i will
take stan lee's word for it it just
makes good sense so impossible man
comes from a planet in the 10th galaxy
called pop-up and pop-up is an extremely
volatile planet constantly changing in
ways that make it more dangerous so the
citizens of pop-up which are of course
called popubians pop-up ians they have
to be highly adaptable in order to
survive so
they are rapidly evolving to meet their
ever-changing demands on the planet now
when we first meet the impossible man
he's on a vacation to earth which leads
to him crossing paths with a fantastic
fork but impossible man is presented as
a comical antagonist instead of a
straight-up villain so he doesn't really
try to destroy the fantastic four he
really just tries to annoy them and he's
actually really successful in doing so
the fantastic four of course realize
that they're powerless to stop
impossible man so they figure out the
only way to get him to go away is to
simply ignore him so they convince
everyone else to ignore him as well and
then he just leaves earth because he
finds it too boring and vows to never
return impossible man has been used
pretty sparingly since then which is to
be expected for a character who is used
almost exclusively for comedic effect
and in fact he doesn't show up again for
13 years next appearing in fantastic
four number 175 in 1976. now in this
issue the fantastic four are engaged in
one of their many conflicts with
galactus and its resolve when the
impossible man shows up and disguises
his home planet pop-up as a moon which
galactus eats now impossible man
explains that basically all of his
people had merged themselves into one
hive mind and were contained within
himself so the extra bodies were all
superfluous so they disguised themselves
as humans so galactus would basically
eat the planet and when he ate that
planet it gave him a case of terminal
indigestion not even lying not even
lying to you guys that's exactly how
it's written so and the next issue
impossible man goes back to earth with
the fantastic four and he learns what
comic books are and decides that he
wants to be the star of his own comic
book so he begins mimicking the powers
of many marvel superheroes such as
turning himself into captain america's
shield or giving himself cyclops optic
blast turning his arm into mjolnir or my
personal favorite giving himself the
little wings on namore's feet that allow
him to fly i love those little wings
they're adorable
he goes to the marvel's offices and
starts demanding that they make a comic
book out of him and when they refuse he
starts destroying stuff now eventually
the fantastic four show up and try to
convince stan lee to make an issue about
the impossible man and he initially
refuses until the thing literally
threatens to punch stan lee now once
they leave
we see roy thomas and george perez who
are the writer and artist of this issue
ask if they should get started on that
issue but stan lee simply tells them
that marvel doesn't have time to make
comics about such a ridiculous character
and as he says this he's standing in
front of a poster of howard the duck so
this is all kinds of meta commentary of
marvel breaking the fourth wall and just
poking a bit of fun of themselves but
after this the impossible man actually
stays around for quite a few issues and
helps out the team while reed and ben
are trapped in the negatives up as for
his powers his primary ability is that
he can rearrange the molecules that
basically make up his anatomy to take on
any form he chooses not only can he copy
the shape of anything or anyone but like
i said earlier he can also mimic the
abilities of super powered individuals
like he did with cyclops and his optic
blasts and he also mimicked the powers
of all four members of the fantastic
four magneto and wasp among others but
his molecular manipulation abilities are
not limited to simply changing his size
and his shape he also is able to change
the composition of his body to differing
materials such as changing into a sheet
of solid steel or becoming one of the
galaxy's heaviest materials so that ben
grimm cannot lift him he can also change
his state of matter to liquid or gas if
he chooses and when he decided to become
water he was able to extinguish the
human torch's flank now he also has
repeatedly demonstrated inability to
duplicate himself and even created a
wife and several thousand children for
himself which all share the same
consciousness and has claimed that he
has the capacity to create nine billion
unique beings now although impossible
man is not known for his fighting
ability he has been able to hold his own
with some pretty heavy hitters the
reason for this is not really due to his
offensive capabilities even though he
had knocked the thing through a wall
after he transformed his fists and
mjolnir but because of his insane
durability he's been punched by the hulk
without being injured and even recovered
from an attack from the molecule man
who's one of the most powerful
characters in the marvel universe and
after he recovers he develops an
immunity to the molecule man's molecular
manipulation abilities and arguably his
most impressive feat he was able to
resist the reality warping powers of
amatsu mikabashi the chaos king and if
you're not familiar with who that guy is
he's one of the biggest threats that the
marvel universe has ever seen and
actually threatened the existence of the
marvel multiverse and even though
impossible man was eventually
overpowered by the chaos king the fact
that he was able to mount any resistance
at all when some of the most powerful
heroes were completely unable to do so
is a testament to just how powerful the
impossible man is and also suggests that
he himself possesses reality warping
abilities in addition to matter
manipulation now this is further
supported by the fact that he's been
able to control time and create powers
which beasts of the x-men described as
reality bending technology on another
occasion impossible man was able to
combine the hulk and red hulk into a
singular entity called the compound hulk
that was literally half red and half
green and ridiculous looking as it
sounds right it looked ridiculous but it
was cool and even galactus has attested
to impossible man's insane power level
stating that in his own way impossible
man represented as big of a threat as
the phoenix force now if you're a fan of
dc comics you may have noticed a lot of
similarity between the impossible man
and mr millennial a frequent antagonist
of superman who also possesses reality
warping abilities and in fact these two
characters actually cross paths back
when marvel and dc we're willing to work
together instead of acting like petulant
children and creating stories for both
sides to enjoy and bicker over endlessly
as to whether or not it was the right
choice
but regardless these two actually battle
pretty evenly for most of the issue and
although we don't see who wins the fact
that impossible man could seemingly
stalemate mr moon is yet another
testament to his power level in fact
it's even been heavily implied in one
issue of superman that impossible man is
simply the form that blah blah takes
when he visits the marvel universe
although the fact that they later fought
suggests that must not be the case so at
any rate that's the impossible man a
really powerful character used in the
most ridiculous manner possible every
time we see him so let me know in the
comments if you guys think that marvel
should use the impossible man more or if
you think he might show up in the mcu
and the fantastic four introduced i
doubt that happens but it'd be cool if
it did right it'd be an impossible feat
for an impossible man
i will see myself out
peace